this program is brought to you by Emory
University
the progress
in let enormously because of the
development of the treatment and the
development of the test of course that
was a first step if people are not
tested and found HIV positive they
cannot have access to the treatment so
and as I said as a treatment today is
not on your benefit for the patient and
we learned that if a patient is treated
very early the benefit in terms of
survival is even much better than if a
patient is treated late so of course
everyone has to be tested as early as
possible to get benefit of the treatment
we learned also that the treatment is
not a benefit at individual level for
the patients that I chai Li positi but
we learned during the last years that
the treatment is very important for
prevention as well recently as it has
been a very nice data published by Myron
Cohen here in United State showing that
clearly showing that in several
discordant couple if the partner
positive partner is treated very early
then there is a reduction of the risk of
transmission to the negative partner by
ninety-six percent
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University